[Music]
so Tom you asked the question how does
mass increase as you go faster and this
is really a wonderful part of Einstein's
theories it actually is also relatively
slippery and kind of complicated because
to even answer this question at all we
have to ask the rather strange question
what do you mean by mass what is your
definition of mass you may have heard
that nothing with mass can possibly go
at the speed of light the only things
that travel at the speed of light are
photons pure energy light the speed of
light nothing with any mass at all can
travel at the speed of light because as
it gets closer and closer to the speed
of light its mass increases and if it
were actually traveling at the speed of
light it would have an infinite mass so
think about that even if you had a tiny
little particle that was say billions of
times less massive than an electron just
a tiny tiny little piece of mass if for
some reason that tiny thing accelerated
to the speed of light it would have an
infinite mass and that's a bit of a
problem so let's talk about this one of
the things that you really have to
realize is the speed of light is very
very special it's not just simply a
speed of something moving through space
as you go faster and faster and closer
to the speed of light time itself begins
to slow down and space begins to
contract as you go close to the speed of
light the entire universe becomes
smaller and smaller until it basically
becomes a single point when you're going
at the speed of light and time as you go
closer to the speed of light get slower
and slower until basically time is a
single point at the speed of light light
does not experience space or time it's
not just a speed going through something
all of the universe shifts around this
constant the speed of light time and
space itself stop when you go that speed
so the reason you can't accelerate to
the speed of light and the reason we say
you have an infinite mass it's a little
complicated because the idea that mass
actually is a measurement of energy you
may remember Einstein's famous equation
equals MC
energy equals mass times the speed of
light squared energy and mass are
equivalent mass is basically a
measurement of how much energy there is
in an object when you're moving you have
the energy of your motion - that's
called kinetic energy energy of motion
so equals MC squared now your mass has
not just the stuff that's in you but
also the energy of your motion and
that's why mass seems to increase as you
go faster and faster and closer to the
speed of light it's not that you're
actually getting any heavier the
increase in mass is something that's
only observed by people that are
watching you go by if you're on a
spaceship going very fast to the speed
of light you don't notice anything
getting heavier you are on your
spaceship you can jump up and down you
can skip rope you can do whatever you
want you don't notice any change at all
but if people try to measure your mass
as you go by they not only are measuring
your rest mass you know we are masked
when you were still but this added
energy of this huge speed that you have
through space and that's called a
relativistic mass it's a complex idea to
think that mass itself is a measurement
of energy so that changes depending on
how fast you're going if you were to
slow down on your spaceship you would
not keep that mass you would go back to
being the same mass you were before you
started moving back quickly so as you
can see it's a complicated answer
depending on how you define mass because
as you're going very close to the speed
of light and you have a huge speed you
need to take into account that energy
because of the equation equals MC
squared
[Music]
you